acorralado pero firme así luce
actualmente el primer ministro británico
boris johnson luego de que fuese
revelado el informe final elaborado por
la alta funcionaria británica sucre y
que sorprendió a johnson por su
contenido en el que se presentan
fotografías donde se le observa
ingiriendo bebidas alcohólicas junto a
otras personas cuando en teoría todos
los ingleses deberían obedecer las
estrictas medidas por los confinamientos
y siento abrumadoramente que es mi
trabajo seguir adelante y cumplir y no
importa cuan a marcas y dolorosas sean
las conclusiones de esto y lo son tengo
que seguir adelante y el gobierno tiene
que seguir moviéndose hip hop con wii
wii
su grey fue designada para llevar
adelante la investigación sobre el
denominado parque un escándalo que ha
salpicado a la administración de johnson
por una serie de reuniones en downing
street celebradas en 2020 y 2021 en
plena crisis sanitaria por el cob y 19
por aquel entonces a los ingleses del
común no se les permitía siquiera
visitar a sus familiares enfermos
trabajó por más de 20 meses analizando
la situación y entre sus conclusiones
destaca una cultura que permitió
congregaciones festivas que no debieron
haber ocurrido
83 funcionarios fueron multados entre
ellos el propio primer ministro
convirtiéndose en el primero en
quebrantar la ley mientras ejercen el
cargo
de
ley muchas de las cosas que viene el
informe esta mañana eran nuevas para mí
pero creo que es importante déjenme
decirlo de esta manera creo que es
importante que todos los que se nombran
los que no han sido nombrados o los
involucrados de alguna manera tienen que
aprender la lección
anyway involved in the show show
business
desde la reacción de johnson no convence
a la oposición su líder kirsch timer
aseguró que las revelaciones del reporte
confirman que el premier trató los
sacrificios del pueblo británico durante
la pandemia con desprecio